Hi, everybody.
My name is Hannah Podzorski.
And today I want to
talk to you about how
I adapted current tools
in environmental science
through R by advocating
for automation.
And to start, I want to
tell you a little bit
about my colleague,
Let's call him John.
I work with a lot of John's.
John might be a biologist, a
chemist, maybe a geologist.
He's been in his field
for quite some time,
and he has a lot of very
important technical knowledge
within his field, but little
to no knowledge on modern day
programming languages.
In addition to this, John
keeps getting handed data
sets that are much larger
and more complex than what
his current tools can handle.
And on top of this, just
like everybody else,
he's got too many tasks
and not enough time.
So this is the type
of scenario where I
would advocate for automation.
My goal is to streamline
the processing of data,
so my team has more time to
apply their technical knowledge
to the problem at hand.
But John might be a
little bit hesitant,
and I understand that
because as a programmer,
I would much rather spend
five days automating something
than 5 minutes to
do a simple task.
And because of that,
not only today
am I going to talk
to you about how
I used R to automate
workflows, but also how
I reduced the
activation energy it
took to get my team on board.
So in chemistry,
activation energy
is the energy needed to get from
one side of a chemical reaction
to another.
And you can reduce
the activation energy
by applying a catalyst.
So when I want to move my team
from their current workflow
to an automated workflow, I can
reduce the activation energy
by rephrasing how
I pitch automation,
starting small, and being
a little bit creative.
So let's start with the
pitch and most importantly,
that word automation.
It can be a little vague
and feel dependent.
But what I mean when
I say automation
is the streamlining of
a workflow by reducing
unnecessary human interactions.
So my team has more time to
spend on greater value tasks.
And most times when
I pitch automation,
I don't even use
the word automation.
I say, "Let's streamline
this workflow!"
So let's talk about the
difference between workflow
that I traditionally
see, which I'm
going to call for the purposes
of this talk, reactionary
workflow and automated workflow.
So let's say we have 4
work products A, B, C and D,
A might be our
database, B might be
our tables full of summary stats,
C is our figures, and D is
the text that goes
into our final report.
Say we have to
update our database.
Maybe we know that we need to
update our database, like we
need to go out and collect more
data, or maybe we don't know
and maybe someone found an
error in unit conversions
at the last minute.
Well, with this
change now we have
to manually update all of
the workflow downstream,
where in comparison, in an
automated workflow, if you have
to make that one change
to your database,
you can use functions
or scripts to automate
the processing of that
one edit and apply it
to all of your work
products downstream.
And this is, I know, a
very simple definition
of what automation is and
streamlining of workflow,
but I like to lay
it out like this
because it makes the pros or
benefits of using automation
very obvious.
So number one, reproducibility,
because of those scripts
or those recipes that are
being completed by a computer,
you know, you're going to get
the same thing every time.
And this is important not
just when you can predict
you need to update
something, like we're
going to do annual
sampling events,
but also when you
can't predict you're
going to need to have
to update something,
like when you catch an error in
a simple mathematic equation.
Also, it can be
extremely simple,
and though it pains me to say
this, this type of workflow
can be accomplished
in Excel workbooks,
just maybe not at the
current scale we need.
It saves time because you're
reducing that human interaction
and also reducing
the amount of errors,
which saves my team time in
quality control and quality
assurance.
So I found it helpful
to start small
with tasks that can be automated
in the same amount of time
as the original tasks.
And so for me and the
projects I work on,
this is most likely
going to be moving
tables of summary
statistics and figures out
of Excel and into R.
But most importantly, I like
to try and meet my team members
where they are, and that's
going to be by creating work
products they're familiar with.
And at least in my case,
that's going to most likely
be Microsoft Office products.
So I'm going to talk about two
packages I love for doing this,
the first one being openxlsx.
It's a package designed
to edit, read, and create
Excel files in R.
So traditionally when I go
to save a dataframe in R,
I'm going to write it as a CSV.
However, more
recently, I've tried
to force myself to
save more of these data
frames, especially
the ones I know
that are going to be of interest
to my team, to Excel files.
And that's because
I want to help them
with this transition between
the reactionary workflow
and the automated workflow.
Because when they're
working on so many projects
at the same time, and they're
used to all their files
being dynamic and
constantly changing,
and also all written in excel,
and you throw one CSV in there,
more than once
have they opened
that CSV in excel,
added a few tabs,
highlight a few cells,
saved it, and closed out.
And since those edits
are not supported in CSV,
they just lost all that work.
So by me making the simple
change of simply saving
data frames as .xls
files, I'm helping
to reduce the activation energy
and get my team moving forward
towards automation.
Also, I love openxlsx
because it allows
me to make formatted Excel
tables in R such as the one
that you see here.
And it's great for when
I have to put together
hundreds of tables that will
go into the back
of a report, which I'm
sure eventually one day
someone might look at, maybe.
Also, I love to use
officer. officer allows you
to manipulate word documents
and PowerPoint
documents in R. I use it
mostly for exporting
ggplots into PowerPoint.
And so here's just example
code doing just that.
But what I want to do is I
want to point out the rvg
package and the function dml.
So running your ggplot
object through this--
in our case, our ggplot object is
"plot"--through this function
before you export that
figure to PowerPoint
allows you to actually edit
that figure in PowerPoint.
So here's an example of a
plot I created and exported
to PowerPoint using the code
from the previous slide.
It's the concentration
of chloride over time
and since I use
the dml function,
I can move around my
annotations, change them,
I can change the axis
titles and the legend.
And this is great for if my team
wants to just have a little bit
more control of
the final product
or if they just don't like where
the annotation is currently at,
or if they want to make
last minute nomenclature
adjustments, this makes it
great so we can still interact.
In addition, with officer, you
can use PowerPoint templates
to create placeholders,
and then you
can add things like figure
captions, figure numbers,
notes, logos.
So I can automate the process
of creating these figures
and export them
from R into PowerPoint
so they're ready for a report.
So now that I've got my
team a little bit on board,
I've started with
these smaller tasks.
Now I can take on
bigger tasks that
might require a little bit
more of an initial investment
and delayed gratification.
So I'm going to talk just about
that, a specific example where
my team decided to
automate software developed
by a regulatory agency.
So that software is ProUCL.
ProUCL was developed by the
US Environmental Protection
Agency, or EPA,
and it specializes
in performing statistical
analysis on Left Censored data.
In Environmental
Sciences, we have
a lot of left censored data.
We, whenever we're measuring the
concentration of some compound
in water or soil
or air, depending
on our methods and our
equipment, we have something
called a detection limit.
And below that
detection limit, we
don't know where that
concentration will sit.
It can be anywhere between
0 and our detection limit.
So there's a lot of
uncertainty around that.
So ProUCL takes that
uncertainty into account
when doing the statistics,
when doing simple statistics
like means and
standard deviations,
as well as more complex
statistics like distributions
and upper confidence limits.
So ProUCL is definitely, it's
solving a problem for us,
but it has some less than great
design features, one of which
is it will crash if you
put too much data into it.
And by too much I mean
about 10,000 records,
which for the type of
projects we're working on,
which require us
to analyze hundreds
of compounds in a variety
of environmental media,
we were having to run
ProUCL multiple times,
and because of that, we decided
we wanted to try and automate
it, and we decided to try and
automate it by using a mini--
a mouse macro.
So in our case, it's
called a mini mouse macro
and basically automate the
clicking of the software
itself.
So we wrote a function
in R that allows
us to subset that data into
more manageable chunks.
And then you run
the function and it
creates an input file
for our mouse macro
and then it runs that file.
So the mouse macro input
is just a simple text file.
I use some command line code
to open up the mouse macro
and load in the
input file and then
it just clicks through
the software for you.
So here it's using
the text string
we gave it to input the
location of the input file.
It's clicking through all
of the dropdowns we'll need
and then it's loading in the
compounds we want to look at.
And finally, it'll save
that file to the text string
I gave it for the output file.
And then once it senses
that there is information
in that file, it will close out
of ProUCL, and if necessary,
run it again.
So we'll loop this over
and over and over again.
And that might have seemed like
a very simple process.
Why would you automate it?
Well, that was a
very small data set,
and there's actually a
lot of computation time
that has to go into it when
you're doing larger data sets.
So for small projects,
running ProUCL
through the automation like
this can take 15 to 30 minutes.
But for bigger projects,
we're talking just
automating like
this 6 to 8 hours.
So it's definitely
saving us time that way.
But writing the code to
automate the clicking of my mouse
through the software was
actually the easy part.
The hard part was
deciphering the output file.
So here's what ProUCL
gives you as an outfit file.
It's a formatted Excel sheet.
This is just a small subsection
of the statistics it gives
you and only one compound.
So once again, for
our sites, we're
looking at hundreds of
compounds and we might even have
to group our data spatially,
so we will need
additional information.
And so before we automated,
what we did was just
have someone go through
and copy and paste
the values we were
really interested in.
And that took quite some time.
So instead, we
automated it and now we
create tables both
unformatted and formatted
in Excel that my team can
use for their analysis
and their final report.
So overall, my team
thinks this went great.
It does exactly what
we want it to do.
When we first decided we
wanted to automate ProUCL,
we saw two paths
we could go down,
one using our mouse macro,
the other just recreating all
of the statistical tests in R.
And that definitely
would have been possible,
but at the time we just didn't
have the resources or the time
to devote to such a project.
In addition, ProUCL
is an industry standard almost
at this point.
It's been used for
quite some time
and there's a lot of important
technical knowledge built
into it.
So using it is a benefit,
especially when we
have to deal with regulators.
In addition, ProUCL
is used on projects
such as risk
assessments where we
look at how compounds
in the environment
can affect different receptors,
like humans and wildlife.
And sometimes we have
to go back and forth
with regulatory agencies to
define our conceptual model
for a site, which means we
might be adding in receptors,
we might be adding
in compounds, we
might be changing how we
spatially divide up our data.
And that means we
very rarely have
to just run ProUCL once,
usually two or three times.
So automating it
definitely saved time.
It saved human error because
less copying and pasting.
But it's not perfect.
Once, I'm sure,
one day, hopefully EPA
will update ProUCL
and then my code
will become obsolete.
But at this point, it's
already paid for itself.
It works.
It does what we need it to
do, and we're happy for that.
In addition, there
are other things
I wanted to do to help
improve this function,
to make it easier to
use for anybody.
But we just didn't
have the time.
So it does require some
special setup, especially
with the coordinates for
the clicking of the mouse.
You have to make sure
your screen resolution is
set appropriately.
So final thoughts.
I gave you a bunch of different
hybrid approaches to automation
that helped me save time and
reduce human error, which
ultimately is what I believe
the goal of automation
is and should be.
Also, I showed some easier
examples and some more
advanced, so I hope
you recognize that
no matter what your skill set,
you can benefit your team now.
And maybe with just a little
bit of rephrasing of your pitch,
starting small and
being creative,
you too can help.
You can reduce the
activation energy
needed to get your team on
board and reduce the road
bumps along the way.
And with that, if we have, I can
go ahead and answer questions.
Also, I wanted to
let everybody know
at this link are my slides
as well as example code
for the smaller examples.
So the open xlsx and
the officer as well as links
to more information.